[Applause]
aaron rodgers
he said he was i'm immunized against a
virus he didn't say i'm vaccinated which
is real [ __ ] yeah sneaky warding i'm
immunized against coven 19. which i
think he did like apparently he did like
a homeopathic thing yeah and then
petitioned the league for this to work
and they were like no dude they said
absolutely [ __ ] not yeah i'm
listening to listen to you and your
[ __ ] shaman or whatever apparently
his wife is super into like traditional
like healing [ __ ] yeah shailene woodley
yeah she came out with like a clay
eating thing that like helps you recover
from
detox and [ __ ] yeah so shailene woodley
um
is his wife and shailene woodley is also
like mad close with uh
with miles teller
they're like they've done movies
together like best friends they go on
vacation that's supposed to impress me
in any way no no because miles teller
also is like unvaccinated and doesn't
believe in any of this stuff and shut
down a movie set for like two years i
heard that yeah yeah so that
people in comment sections and things
like that are like oh she's the north
star of like
ruining million dollar production
so is his wife's fault uh i don't know
it's her fault but i mean like he's
i mean he's with her and she also
doesn't believe in he does he's
immunized like
here's what's interesting apparently
there are reports that he is walking
around on the sideline with no mask as
if he's vaccinated because the rule is
if you're not vaccinated you have to
have a mascot i'm pretty sure sideline
vaccinated unboxing you don't have to as
long as you adhere to the unvaccinated
protocol that the nfl put out i think
that isn't adhering to the unbelievable
yeah i think that is one of the
protocols coaches coaches have to
regardless i'm pretty sure but players
players if you're vexed no mask
if you're unboxed mask
that's i'm pretty sure the rule now yeah
because if you're on vaccine and not
wearing a mask that's an issue but you
have to get tested for all the games
he's also broken like a billion
protocols and in the next two weeks
they're to be just hundreds of videos
that come out of him traveling with them
eating with them like breaking all the
rules and it's just going to be and
that's what's interesting is do they
suspend aaron rodgers they're gonna yeah
they're gonna they're gonna just because
they're gonna say that he kind of you
know bamboozled a little bit with his
wording yeah and then but then did what
you said then then all the other things
eating walking around with no they're
gonna look like oh so you lied and were
reckless yes and he's probably gonna get
i just don't like that they you know i
know a buddy who's a cop and he's he's
not vaxxed and the mandate they're gonna
you know you guys that's coming in
effect last night i think that that went
into effect i think yeah like this week
or whatever and like that's i gotta be
honest like even though i got vacs
that's [ __ ] up like telling somebody
that they have to
yeah telling somebody that they have to
put something in their body that they're
not comfortable with that's that that to
me is as much of a dictatorship for me
to be like you're not going to earn
money for your family yeah and this is
coming from somebody that got vaccines i
got vaxxed i got vacs i believe in the
vacs me too and for private businesses
okay it's a private business i think the
[ __ ] homophobic dude they didn't want
to make the gay cake alright it's a
private business if you want your
employees to get vacs all right it's a
private business but cops is not private
business yeah and if there's something
like yo you're gonna have to get tested
every day and they're like fine i'd
rather do that than have the vaccine
okay cool right i took my son to the
knicks game you know what he got tested
within two minutes yeah we went to the
knicks game they go just go up the
escalator yourself they were like you
and i will take
yeah my son's like [ __ ] that no he was
he was you know 12 years old before 12
years old at the time definitely don't
get him back and uh yeah and he they
were like oh you'll get the results in
15 minutes it's five minutes later yeah
oh you're good to go go in so have the
cops show up to work [ __ ] a little
early yeah and like if you don't wanna i
mean that that's where i'm just like you
know what man like because people like
oh paul got vacs so does that mean like
if i talk about oh i got vaxxed because
you know you know the line that's right
you can't beat it it's like and i'm like
no no i got vax because i talked to my
doctor and i decided to give vax and i
didn't know if i wasn't going to be able
to travel and make money and my doctor
said it's safe i got decided if somebody
says they don't want to get vex they
shouldn't test them all the time and
make them go through all the [ __ ] that
they have to go through oh and if they
die [ __ ] them i fully agree if you if
you don't get vacs then you die
that's your decision yes but to tell
them that they can't make money unless
they get the needle that's where i think
it's that's that's where you're kind of
that's where it's like not freedom
anymore again i
on private businesses to me i think it's
like to me that's kind of capitalism
where again the guy that didn't want to
make the cake if you don't support his
business he will fail that is capital
let capitalism work let a private
business the vaccine mandate if people
are like yo i'm not going and supporting
that business they'll fail that's
capitalism let that work out but when
it's a government thing i'm a little
more like it's way more gray area cops
government jobs any municipal job any uh
like the federal government employees
had to get the vaccine and i'm like
i get it
and you are a public servant so it's a
little bit different yeah but it's i
don't know it just feels a little weird
to me to mandate that if there's other
ways around it if you have antibodies
you shouldn't have to get the vaccine if
i can show you once every three days
even that even if that's extreme i have
positive i have antibodies for covet i'm
testing positive for antibodies why do
you have to get a vaccine any time i see
a line of people doing something that
they have to
it reminds me of a movie yeah right
anytime you see people online to do
something that they normally don't want
to do that is not free that is a [ __ ]
that is a dictatorship yeah that's yeah
that's the beginning of the rabbit hole
that right there that first thought is
the first thought that starts the rabbit
hole with the you know what man anytime
somebody tells you i have to do
something i don't know what alex jones
is talking about let's just see i'm
curious it's the first step you want to
know you want to laugh i was online i
was like 10 people away from getting the
vax texting friends
should i yeah i swear to god like i was
10 people away and i'm going dude is am
i making the right yeah and my friend
yes get it get on my god my doctor said
it and then i finally did it but i
decided to do it that was my choice yeah
my choice to do it right and and that's
where i just find it a little fun all
right guys we're going to take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip so i
can tell you guys about
performance-enhancing drugs what kind of
performance the sexual kind the only
kind that really matters fellas if you
want to deliver your girl the special
lady in your life maybe the lady you
want to be the special lady in your life
the best dick she's ever gotten in her
life there is only one way to do it it's
blue chew it's chewable it absorbs
faster blah blah blah all the science
who gives a [ __ ] what you need to know
is your dick will be the hardest it's
been the quickest it's been the longest
it's been
it is
the best gift you can give a girl you
care about and ladies if your man is
lacking a little bit
you deserve some blue chew
why do you not you deserve to be
sexually satisfied this is a gift for
him that satisfies you so if you want to
try blue chew all you gotta do is go to
bluechew.com and use the promo code
andrew in honor of our great andrew
schultz on andrew schultz's flagrant two
without andrew schultz
and you will get it for free all you
gotta do is pay five dollars shipping
again that is the best dick you have
ever delivered in your life or ladies
received in your life for free all you
gotta do is pay five dollars shipping if
you go to bluechew.com
promo code andrew now let's get back to
this exclusive patreon clip and guys
patreon.com flagrant2 number one comedy
patreon in the world sign up and come
see why five dollars a month extra
episode every week so worth it yeah no i
get that i also heard somebody
say uh he was talking to an immunologist
who was like he's a pro athlete like a
teenager roger's boy yeah he was a roger
boy he said something like after a
million people get the vaccine if you
don't see short-term side effects with
that million yeah there's almost
historically there's no precedent for
suddenly long-term [ __ ] popping up in
large numbers now there's people who
might say their kid got autism from a
vaccine maybe that happened i don't know
if there's a for sure proof but like
right there there's been that argument
yeah yeah so i to me that made a lot of
sense also which is like all right if a
million people have gotten it and
they've been we haven't heard [ __ ] about
this thing yeah i've actually heard a
couple of people there have been some
side effects in a small number of people
but and that's going to happen we all
have allergies to medication i think
that people i'm sure that the flu shot
i'm sure that the flu shot has done some
[ __ ] to people and i'm sure that yeah
there can definitely be some things but
i don't want this [ __ ] to we listen none
of us know if we're gonna all [ __ ]
our fingers are gonna fall off in three
years we don't know yeah
the thing is science doesn't know we
don't know what the coronavirus is
really gonna do we're hoping it's like
something that we can take control of
yeah but we don't know you know what i
will say and i'm working on a bit about
this if an athlete a person that's in
shape doesn't want to take the vaccine i
might not agree with you but i can't
knock you for it
but a fat person who's not taking the
vaccine yeah i'm not having it no now
you care about your health yeah fat [ __ ]
yeah yeah if lebron james doesn't want
to do it like he's a specimen yeah if
some fat [ __ ] eating cheeseburgers all
the time is like yeah no
mainline inflaming hot cheetos and all
of a sudden now you're health conscious
you're on four blood pressure
medications now big pharma i talked
about that in the special i got friends
you know like yeah you know give me the
cocaine and chocolate leave the
antibodies over there yeah yeah yeah no
no it's i'm with you man yeah and if if
if this hasn't woken fat people up
like if you were fat and survived this
that's then you can't go back new lease
on life you have to if you have to lose
weight now like god gave god spared your
fat ass what are you gonna do you're
gonna throw that blessing back in god's
face
yeah like in a year from now if you see
somebody like 350 walk in the streets
it's just almost like dude you should
give him covet on purpose that's
disrespectful he's in his mouth for god
that's disrespectful if you believe in
god and you see that fat [ __ ]
disrespecting that blessing you should
inject him with kovacs unless those fat
[ __ ] get arrogant they're like covet
didn't even take this fat ass out
god that's the best if you don't believe
covet is like
real if you're like yeah it's not that
big a deal you probably know a lot of
fat people who are still walking around
yeah you're probably like come on come
on yo come on
so if aaron rodgers didn't break
protocol would the league suspend him
still here's i think if he didn't break
protocol he wouldn't have grounds for
suspension because everything i'm
googling now he can slide by on a
technicality saying i'm immunized he
really believes he's immunized so i
don't think it's suspension also lying
to the press like i don't know if that
yeah who gives what's his job but if you
are breaking the league mandated
protocols for vaccinated and
unvaccinated people then that's grounds
for suspension and that's what i'm
curious about it right but then he's
gonna have to prove that he really
believed he was immunized whatever yeah
yeah you know i i don't know if i'm sure
deep down inside he knows
he knows that he lied yeah and then
i
because after the lie you can't wear a
mask
right yeah that's true you can't you
can't tell people that you're good and
then be with a mask on the sidelines
they're gonna be like oh is this guy
this guy's clearly lying so he's gonna
have to try to do that argument saying i
think the [ __ ] that i took
yeah help me yeah but i i think uh you
know i don't know so far what i'm
reading is it doesn't seem like he
anyone has said that he broke protocol
like they're doing internal
investigation there are reports that he
broke protocol now whether or not
there's there are apparently photographs
that exist whether or not that's true
we're going to find out soon and i'm
sure if they exist the packers are doing
everything they can to get that [ __ ]
scrubbed from everywhere right like if
there's team photos cut that [ __ ]
camera's everywhere too and yeah it's
also going to be interesting because
apparently the nfl and green bay both
knew that he was told that what he did
will not count as a kovdak scene but
they both sort of went
all right we've talked about it let's
just move on he's a star player number
one qbr this year like
it's one of those where i think the
green bay packers and the nfl are also
going to look bad like he messes up
because he made a bad choice but they'll
also protect the shield they don't put
players above the league ever so for
them to protect somebody all of a sudden
is going to look well make no make no
mistake if this was ryan tannehill he'd
be [ __ ] suspended yeah if tua did
this he's out
like yeah like this is aaron [ __ ]
rogers and they are also like first
place in the division number one packers
are gonna i mean he's like first place
in the conference maybe because they
beat arizona yeah like they're the best
team in the nfc right now i guess on
paper i don't think i think they're
gonna really the packers are gonna do
everything you can so you know those
videographers right now are scrubbing oh
100 and here's what's actually
interesting for me as a cowboy fan
interesting born and raised in dallas
big cowboy fan okay because i have to be
it's been pretty miserable for the most
part but
they they got a shot at the number one
scene
they got a shot at the bye and part of
me is like yo if aaron rodgers gets
suspended it's that much easier for us
to get a buy like we're that's that's
the guy i fear the most but
if he gets suspended a pissed off aaron
rodgers in the playoffs yeah i don't
think anybody stops him i think
suspending him might be the best thing
you can do for aaron rodgers what is the
uh amount of games suspended he'd be
suspended for two games whatever they
decide really so he has to miss this
game and the earliest he can come back
is saturday just based on testing
positive and being unvaccinated these
are the rules now if they decide you
know you also broke protocol so we're
adding a two three game suspension now
he's out three four games whatever it is
and the packers will 100 not have a
chance at the one seat you know what's
hilarious is that they that jordan love
i think yeah yeah he's coming in and
that's the guy that aaron rodgers was
not happy with yes so if he comes in for
two or three games
and is dope then that that's a whole
other i mean he'll he'll never you're
never going to bench in aaron rodgers
yeah never but
him coming in and being really good is
something that would annoy the then
you've got aaron rodgers really yeah and
aaron is a free agent this year so i
think their dream scenario is jordan
loves shows promise
and then you either don't have to sign
aaron rodgers again or you sign him and
then trade jordan rogers for a boatload
of pictures i think aaron rodgers is
gone i think he's gone i don't think
he's coming back he said something after
the win on thursday about how special it
is to play at lambeau field and how like
he doesn't take this for granted so
maybe that was like a eulogy like like
an early eulogy or if it was like you
know what i do love it here huh little
swan song like yeah maybe that's the way
he's looking at the last dance kind of
thing but that was an interesting all of
a sudden for him to be like this is a
magical place it was also when he scored
the touchdown on the bears and he was
like i [ __ ] own you forever i've
always owned you he i still own you he's
yeah whatever yo the life of a backup
quarterback is [ __ ] hilarious it's so
funny it's so [ __ ] cause like he's at
the club and you know like they're like
yo you got a game tomorrow he's like i'm
not [ __ ] playing what are you talking
about
yeah it's and then he has to go in the
best and the worst job on earth it's the
best job because you're getting paid
you're not getting a [ __ ] cte you
practice you stay in shape whatever you
make millions of dollars legitimately
yeah but if you're not ready at the drop
of a [ __ ] dime yeah it's a real
problem you're probably not gonna work
next year no that's the thing it's like
if you get exposed you're out of a job
you know what it's like it's like
getting paid a million dollars a year to
wait on standby at the airport
you know what i mean like i'm getting
paid and this isn't the worst [ __ ] in
the world but [ __ ] i just always
got to be ready for this flight at all
times i always got to be packed with
yeah just go grab an auntie hands i
can't live like that like even with
comedy when they're like hey man like
you know when you were younger calm down
and see if you get up yeah
am i getting up or not yeah bruh come on
i'm not doing that yo give me a spot or
don't i'm not hanging out all [ __ ]
night fighting your nails yo did you
show up getting in my head yeah hoping
somebody dies in a car crash so i can
get a spot so who's the dude this
feeling is jordan love jordan love was
drafted two years ago that he wasn't
happy and aaron rodgers needed wide
receiver help multiple years in a row
and that year in particular they just
didn't they drafted instead of a
receiver i don't think they took one all
draft and in the first round they took
his replacement so he was just like what
the [ __ ] he's like how are you gonna do
like i'm aaron rodgers yeah what are you
doing yeah like i need help and you guys
decided to do that that made him like
[ __ ] this place right you know that was
the beginning of the end and so how does
this how does jordan love come through
on this game you think i don't think he
does well i haven't heard great things
about it he comes in he's like 25 for 25
five touchdowns like he's just like the
highest rating ever it would be
also chief's defense is terrible right
like chiefs are really struggling right
now
we were talking about that on our
podcast something's wrong with him
something is like it's enough now like i
watch a lot of football we do that for
the best right we do the yeah we do the
the bets the picks versus each other for
the the bet mgm i'm watching this game
and i i got it something is even when
you watch his face
when you watch his face you watch travis
kelsey's face when you see the look and
the demeanor of the chiefs some he's
either hurt something is i've never seen
the guy missed eight misses downfield
that never happened yeah they look bad
against look he's he just like like and
the giants were out of like so many
players and were in the game he was
throwing incomplete packs there were one
off-sized penalty away from winning the
[ __ ] game had an interception at the
end of the game that would have won it
but somebody was offside it was fairly
that new zone in frankfurt he jumped he
jumped early otherwise that game's over
yeah but something is wrong i don't know
if he's hurt i heard some shit's going
on at home like he's got some [ __ ] with
his wife is tweeting [ __ ] out his dad's
running around there's a lot of [ __ ] but
i he just is like he patrol homes never
misses [ __ ] like that
so here's one quote he had a i heard he
had a quote before the giants game which
was i think we've learned we have to
still prepare we have to still do all
the same things we're doing we can't
rest on our laurels essentially which
would be a an indictment of himself
saying i haven't been preparing like i
normally do i've been working like i
normally do i've been kind of coasting
uh so i don't but then he went out and
played like dog [ __ ] against a giant so
i don't know if he fixes it i also think
that to your point the packers could win
without aaron rodgers because patrick
mahomes isn't playing they barely beat
the giants barely yeah that line went to
eight so it's an eighth spread for i
think the chiefs
i would love to see patrick holmes turn
it around and [ __ ] set the world on
fire again and i think if he gets into
the playoffs i'd still fear them more
than anybody else if i'm in the afc but
they just don't look good what up people
you just watch a clip from our weekly
patreon episode you can support the
flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.com
alright peace